you're going to let me
win Mar get me hungry I'm weak I know
but I
win oh why not have a taste of the old
gaju Hollywood vampires Johnny dap don't
forget Johnny dapp and Donald Trump
won you're right I still
stink let's go get you something to eat
and then we'll take me shopping get me
some perfume and stuff let's get you
something to eat first what do you want
today
Mark mommy's
trait what are you hungry for you uh you
you come from money huh you come from
money I come from money yes I come from
an exceptional amount of money and your
parent your parents have probably seen
money these these videos are seen in in
Egypt I'm sure I would imagine is what I
can get away with staying here for you
know what I mean I'm not sure because we
haven't spoken about and you know what I
mean I'm pretty sure if Fred either
would have shown my dad those videos
though so I probably would have ended up
in the news or something like that as
like
for not the best why do you think your
parents have not contacted you I haven't
contacted them but I we've had no way of
contacting each other I wanted to call
my dad remember that one time when I
begged you to call my dad he would still
be supportive of me though see there's
one thing my dad always said when I was
a kid and he was right he's like if it
weren't for me you'd be homeless I'm
like hm he like if it weren't for me
you'd be homeless I'm like huh no way i'
be able to make it for myself little did
I
know your parents May sometimes be right
but he like he literally sacrificed his
whole life for me ish you know what I
mean he had nothing else to do this is
your biological dad or your stepdad my
biological dad my stepdad let's say is
the devil so you
know yeah I told you my real father's
name and I told you that he came from
money but my mother's family was richer
than my father's and when my parents
divorced I went with my father so I lost
on an ex exceptional inher
let's say Mark what's half of $3
billion no really really my grandfather
was in real estate he did um my mother's
father did Real Estate all over the
world so Japan Qatar Korea he's kind of
like you know Muhammad Hadid here he's
like the most famous guy in real estate
here he's like the Muhammad Hadid of
Middle East and he owns compounds in the
Middle East like this is known right I
can say this I don't to say his
name um so I won't just for his sake for
his discretion but literally Mark like
like we had a Salvador Dolly clock in
our [__] foyer but old money so very
like for some reason very um humble I
don't know what to say like we eat like
peasants you know what I mean and like
we go shopping at H&M and Zara it was
really bizarre like had a closet full
had to to of like Burber and amilio
pooie for no reason Uchi who doesn't
even do WS wear I don't you know who
Uchi is he does like um psychedelic
women's wear like full right but then
we'd go shopping at Zara
barely and like not even the mall dude
it was really weird so as I grew up and
it came to be known that I was gay he
just like took steps back and then
eventually like I showed up to his house
and the gate at the compound at which he
lived was like you can't come in here
and it's kind of the treatment I've been
getting out here you know what I mean
where literally won't let me the reason
they probably wouldn't spend money on
you is because they don't approve of you
being gay exactly well now that I'm
trans that's an even bigger issue but
the time I was just gay cuz it came out
um in in the community that I lost my
virginity cuz my cousin found out from
my Facebook to the most awful guy I wish
I'd never done it honestly the most
awful guy Mark can you imagine like like
we just finished having sex in this
abandoned construction site no feelings
no nothing he didn't even kiss me and he
tries to push me off a [__]
roof takes me back to his house feeds me
a cup of instant
noodles and tells me I have to
leave cuz he's uh cuz he got a friend
coming over to game
with on his Xbox not even a PlayStation
Mark a [__] Xbox his name is Manny
Manny Paya is awful awful
awful this was in Egypt this was in
Cairo Egypt yeah in a place called um
ATO huge house by the way huge house
mansion
yeah but anyway being gay or or trans
whatever is a huge deal it's look it is
against the law and you kind of get
arrested for it but a lot of people get
away with it like there's an underground
Community you know what I mean like a
huge underground Community they're I
don't like them honestly because they're
those who try hard you know those
Madonna gays you know what I mean like
gays that are like that don't like women
I love women so it's mostly dudes who
kind of like make fun of women or like
or a bunch of who you know what I mean
like I went to one of their parties and
there were like two women there and they
were both butchies and they were just
hating on women nonstop they were like
[__] women [__] [__] [__] vaginas
we're dudes but they were like really
gay about it too like really like like e
e [__] women I'm like huh I didn't even
know I was trans at time I only found I
was trans when I came to America
honestly like to go look at some drag
queen or something I think it was Gia I
saw Gia you know she's a studio here gun
Studio I saw Gia on TV I'm like a what I
still keep trying to meet her I keep
yelling at her from outside her her
Studio she won't come down like g g i
love you she can't hear me even one of
her videos she's dancing by trash with
Alaska Thunder [__] it's called stun
might be a Zeta princess might not
stun but I can't talk about that cuz
that's secret CIA business
CIA I'm melting I like it when you're
clean Happy Birthday Mr
President happy birthday Sergeant Shaw
Sergeant Raymond sh I know what I do
with the presidency you know what I
mean I don't know honestly I mean I'd be
really good at like um taking care of
business like um subliminally but I
don't if I can be the face of the
presidency you know what I
mean I've three votes for president Mary
Kate her husband her future husband his
name is Jack rockfeller very um
wellknown and underground circles or the
devil if you were to Incarnate how about
we tame him and make him the president
it's like Mr Roger Goes to Washington oh
Roger isn't that Rachel's husband's name
oops it's all coming together but wait
not yet not until the 27
Club they only want you when you're s oh
I didn't notice to turn the other camera
on think Mary Kate and
Ashley weird think Ashley's like a lot
shorter but Mary Kate's a shorter one
and Mary Kate's like the
pyramid Ashley's like like sitting there
with her legs spread you know what I
mean like spread eagle spr spread eagle
cross the block spr spread eagle cross
the block I [__] the music I make it
come didn't death Crips come from
skidrow Death Crips
666 want to deal have no fear comes and
goes have no cuz about what I got to
show for it huh I [__] the music I make
it come I [__] the music with and I'm
not sorry I'm not sorry about it
it's human
nature it's just human nature and I'm
not
sorry nothing wrong with it La baby
Hollywood Hollywood what would I do for6
,000 sex tape my my three rules are no
pain no piss no [__] those are my
threeyear
olds I would like to also add no stunts
no
lines no
[__] but you know I could do a
lineer
two a TH or too just no [__] I'm
still on the
[__] Hollywood also um I do anything for
a costume couch
Geto oh my made in
Italy it's a setup I'm telling you hold
on you knocked the microphone off again
it's a setup black magic design
di you [__] devil just leave it right
here that'll work oh that'll work just
fine
meow
meow I'll be the one that gives the pain
can take it away not too close say Happy
Birthday Mr
President anyway not too close stop
face not
face
oh is the phone charged uh it's been
charging the whole time so it's probably
fully charged I would hope so honestly
this phone Tak so long in
charge so I had the purse I have the and
I have the phone Heidi is Heidi is
texting back what is she saying I asked
I asked her if she wanted to oh she just
backed out of it so she did not see the
last celebr I communicated on a phone
with was the ganja estra my friend down
in Van I can't remember her name weird I
used to go to her place all the time I
can't remember her name
anyway she a Wich or something anyway so
so so Heidi F's reaction uh response to
my invitation to join us audio phone
only on a video with you is wow you're
you're with the spectacular Rebecca a
guy
named she knows me is hi yeah she knows
you from my channel how do you find
knows who I am oh she she has she has a
a visitor coming by in a minute M I
don't care I don't care it's fine it's
fine let her do whatever it's her life
it's her life oh my God how I am it's
over it's over kill me now K me now it's
over it's done okay okay we can do this
Mark I mean maybe another time Heidi's
very nice oh was that [__] she's very
cool birth a star born to be a star what
was it again um what's that lady the
Judy Garland one lady
G birth of a star what's it called not
birth of nation what's it called I'm not
sure creation of a star what's it called
Star is Born huh A Star is Born A Star
is Born
Everybody Wants To Be Hollywood the
Glamour the You' got what it takes more
than anybody I've ever met one day I'm
going to be a big look at look at Sharon
Stone now you know what I mean like it's
a big deeper and maybe one day you can
visit my condo on a big hill you know
like
90210 you say I'm not fabulous I'm rich
I'm vanish Fame I'm
Glitz I am the story I am the star are
you know leg big
dier season G 678 13
oops everybody wants to be
Hollywood and maybe one day you can
shake my hand on the Planet
Hollywood cuz you're
holwood
Hollywood
can I get you back can I get your back
in frame a little bit F
fatal they kind of feel like anime Wong
right now is there an Asian F
fatal that's good de right sorry I hope
I didn't spit on you but I'm sure I need
a drink after meal there scoot over a
little bit this way huh scoot over a
little bit this way please thank you
finally
Direction got to be starting
something see much like Hitler before me
when Hitler was a young
kin was little paintings they wouldn't
let him in their
stores and somehow he ended up becom the
leader
of West Germany or was it all Germany of
v
in Black Hitler
Beverly
Hills that's where I want to be but hly
I hate day I think it's very talky you
know what I mean the the exposed brick
you know that it's like see I'm I'm a
straight guy and I enjoy hanging out
with you when you're not too high a [__]
piece of [__] no I'm not annoying piece
of [__] not you're a blast I'm high as
[__] right now you're I'm not high as
[__] I'm like I'm highish I had four
hits four hits yeah maybe five well why
are you so [__] crazy sometimes S I
think it's because of the Barefoot thing
honestly cuz I'm barefoot walking around
alone you know what I mean the reason
your feet the reason your feet are
hurting is cuz you haven't slept
barefoot no because I walk around
Barefoot yeah but that doesn't help but
you're also not sleeping for three days
I don't do the cavy Fe thing cavy Fe
comes from cavy I don't do no it com
from from crystal meth too I don't do
crack no it doesn't come from Crystal
yes it does it doesn't it does it
doesn't it it comes from the lack of
sleep it doesn't come from the lack of
sleep it because I'm walking around
Barefoot in the street you're walking
around Barefoot without without sleeping
you got to give your feet rest
it's not about sleeping by the way it is
about sleeping it's not about sleeping
it is about sleep I sleep I just slept
for the last two days I try to sleep at
least one day a
week really no cuz people who do crystal
everyone here does crystal math they
they don't sleep for months you know
what I mean mhm right I'm like I have a
history of vampirism so I know that i'
I've seen you passed down on the
sidewalk like a dead body I know
disgusting where tell me uh the corner
of uh spring and 9th I think once spring
and 9th where is that just like it's
it's a pretty fairly quiet quiet block
mhm or maybe it was main JB Clothier
might have been Main Street and 9th
yeah across from uh the
ace I'm not sure you know I just you
know Cory and I will drive around and
this is this you wake me up of course no
I I tried to and you wouldn't you would
not oh yeah no no when I'm asleep yeah
no no no no no why came kicked me in the
head today that's doesn't get up you you
were you were basically dead except you
were breathing yeah blood on her skin
dripping
with sin do it again Living Dead Girl
well I'm half dead half alive I'm a dead
girl in the body of a living
boy blue
boy poor me I have a
penis but I want to be a real woman so
you do want to be a I really want to be
a woman I hate my dick honestly I mean
I'm I get a lot of crap I see in the
comments it will give me a hard time cuz
I don't accept your transgender no it's
not that you don't accept it it's just
that I don't come across as so willing
well no no no here's here's what I think
the problem is yeah I I I've have had a
lot of experience with transgenders down
here and and every single one of them
almost every single one has been some
sort of like just very devious Hustler
I'm not exactly I know I know you're not
no I know you're not so that that's part
of the problem and I've also interviewed
a few people who had regrets they had
the surgery I regret it up no I up until
but but but here's the here's the
biggest part of it you are I I find you
to be one one of the most handsome males
I've ever seen but I don't like my mail
I understand I understand I get that but
you're you're just so incredibly
handsome that very ugly boy you you get
to look like George cloy or Brad Pit I
mean that's I see the Brad Pit part but
honestly I'd rather look like Jennifer
hon or Andre Jolie that's I know I get
you want to be a woman I get it do like
just like a Jolene Haw
is is no I understand that this is
something that people just don't change
scl johans said ay both had no tits no
ass no sex appeal no if some guys like
SC hson did eight like a freak and then
she did the
change as an A to Z there's there's a
girl for every
guy and there's a man for me I'm sure
there is I'm sure there is I love you
loto but he's more like a Playboy I
don't know if he's my husband or my it's
like Cleopatra and Caesar he'd be Caesar
and I'd be
Cleopatra I know he wants me because I
met him once in a club in New York but
at the time I wasn't really seeing guys
so I didn't really approach I was kind
of shy but he winked at me so we on two
baby I love you L you'd probably be an
attractive female too I'm not attracted
to you I'm not attracted you I'm sorry I
find you attractive but I'm not
attracted to you I get it but I find you
very attractive no I with your body is
insane for your age I would be but
honestly you just you don't have like an
mm look like I don't know like a like a
Ser no I mean there's there's different
I don't take it but you're so beautiful
well thank you you are too I I just I
just think you're super attractive
however I just want you know that I
don't want to sleep with you I'm not
into the men this is a very but but but
if if I was a female I would think oh my
God you are my dream oh my God ew I
don't understand that honestly because I
don't find women attractive at all I
find women beautiful I can cast women
and I see them as goddesses honestly see
as above men and I'm very picky with my
men but I see women as like way above
also you never question smart soft my
underbelly what's the belly of the
Beast what's what what's the belly of
the Beast Beast what is the belly of the
Beast I don't know what the belly is
September 16th 2023 it's today what's
the belly of the
Beast are we Conjuring
someone he's just looking for his tail
your mic is too far away from your mou
the mic is too far away from the map the
Mark's too far away from the
penis my eyes are up here
Mark casc Pro huh I didn't realize you
you heard that Disney show casy
undercover saring Zena I didn't realize
you only had one nut yeah I think I
mentioned it once but you know yeah but
I don't a lot of things you say I don't
take seriously yeah honestly most of the
time ex sitting there like rubbing my
feet like oh my feet are hurting ow ow
ow the belly of Beast I'm just stealing
souls are they stealing like who you are
now you are you are finally hirable I
believe I'm getting there I don't even
think I'm I've approached I see I can be
a lot more um I don't want to say
deceitful I can definitely be much more
of a professional about it I'm just I'm
at my own wits end with myself I don't
know what to do with myself how dare I
have living on the street must be so it
is exhausting I'm no and and and for
your self worth and you're do no just
there's nothing to do you know no but
just having a professional attitude like
you know what on Monday I'm going to
show for work I'm going to do a good job
you don't you can't even imagine that I
just hoping fashion like I don't know if
they hire me or not I hope so I mean
they've hired worse you know what I mean
well you're you're one of the most
intelligent John Gano was homeless and
so is Alexander McQueen so I'm thinking
that there's just you know hope is
an and I love the LA fashion scene it's
very different from the New York Fashion
scene so I'm hoping this still a shot
you know what I mean I'm not saying I
want to work at V honestly my dream is W
I've always wanted to work at w but like
that's later in life you know what I
mean MH well Stephen and gone came here
from the Philippines like nothing on his
I'm pretty sure sucked a dick to make V
magazine in v i met him once I remember
I met him twice actually once outside V
he didn't say anything and the second
time we were outside of CA watch a movie
called L starring Isabelle Hopper which
would relate to our dear friend antler
back there and he goes what the [__] are
you doing here I'm like excuse me the
[__] did you just say bye [__] and then
I walked off I didn't know what to
say I'm looking at like my alma Mo my
goddess my Iselle
hoer if if I was a fashion designer in N
LA and I saw you today I said if you if
you could stay in this Frame of Mind
I got a job for you okay do but if you
yeah I mean but I'm not one I'm sorry
but I know I know I just I want to sty
honly if if you need an assistant you
know what I mean speed the plow but you
are you are super intelligent Super
Creative I'm really not very smart and I
don't know how to do anything with my
hands but I have potential I have the
spirit of it look how you turn Street
scraps into art you do it every day Mark
you're so lovely I'm improvisational
honestly like I see it in myself but
that's where I say I'm a witch because
I'm beyond myself 3:55 God we're already
late
I wasn't she sick in um my fair lady was
she sick or not I don't remember was she
sick or not it'll be important for the
for the moment in my fa lady did you
have a cough or not I don't think so I
don't know cuz they going Mar Poppin so
[__] Mar Poppin yeah a presidential
model
what I can look the other way about it
cuz honestly I'm here to hire
presidential
model um I I don't know if I want it or
not you know what I
mean do you know running MP PM I'd go
with MP rather be a master
programmer I'd love to be the president
but honestly
like
why I'd rather be the mother of the
president you know what I mean but I'd
rather my father be the president I'd
rather the devil be the president truly
that's what America deserves
this will be the longest Rebecca video
ever huh this will be the longest
Rebecca video ever oh [__] it how long
have we been talking
50 well earlier this morning we did
something and now now it's almost an
hour an hour mhm wow so that therapy
session you were wanting so much see we
can we can uh converse that's right
that's a therapy sessioning out I'm
getting bored aist you drain me of all
my energy you vampire that's what you
look like you look like a vampire you
know do a British vampire
or maybe French Lithuanian British
Lithuanian yeah pretty much you f scum
scum you're scum I love Russia I love
Russians we're right next door hm
Lithuania is right next door to Russia
yeah but it isn't Russia it is not it's
poor so it's Bulgaria but the bulgar
snake that's a Roth child
a they own it it's
disgusting it's how you make a deal upar
I feel very sorry for my family cuz
um they still try to make Penance with
God they still believe in their
Judaism even though they're the most
evil family in the world they own all
the banks all the money so you're you're
Jewish I am tempted by Judaism honestly
prefer Islam I'm a
witch I practice through religion if
you're asking one thing I'd say I was a
Roman Catholic mhm cuz then it appeals
to me the the idea of uh doing that to
boys and God's acceptance of it but I do
have Jewish blood in me and I am an
ashic Jew so I'd have to say that yes
I'm an osic Jew I have an ashic jewish
blood line meaning I'm related to the r
chop family because it's the same tribe
meaning it makes me a Roth child it's
the same family it's just um child of
Roth Roth means god so they're the
children of God that's when say when
they say God's chosen people so it's
like um the Fallen ones you know what I
mean yeah it's not rth it's Roth and
you've got D Shield as an of Roth child
and you got Roth's child which is Roth's
child in it's either slave or belonging
to either way it's all about ownership
and but they're real family you know
it's just look at David the [__] the
[__] tell me the world's most luxurious
familyi the Rothchild
taste
Mar [__] [__] and I've got Jacob and
David DJ going to burn this goddamn
house right now there's a murder on the
do yes a house right
there our house in the middle of the
streets anyway
so my you can call me that for now I
even offered it and I accepted 94 699 I
love this Rebecca 99
9964 carry on
dadman you love this Rebecca this
Rebecca loves you or does she love your
money no she loves
you no you see you don't play me for
money like a lot of people that I
interview do I'm not obvious about it no
because there have been how many times
that I've seen you on skidrow just three
four blocks from here and you could
easily come by here and get some free
cash but it's actually very hard to get
up in the wall don't ask me so I'm ready
to to get up and hustle at life you know
you got a h hustle and you got a hustle
Lisa Rena
2022 copyright yeah I was in that
dependence commercial who's your
favorite
actors don't do that too many Jean M
Jean Mo Jean Mo yeah yeah you have great
taste H you have great taste I know I
do only like a few movies who's your
favorite male actor huh who's your
favorite male actor o
you say Brad Pit is sexy I don't like
men you know what I mean Brad Pit's
great though Brad Pit is sexy but
despite the fact that Brad Pit is so
wildly Su I don't like him now no can I
add a second choice Brad Pit isad Brad
Pit is great I say say [__] B he does a
lot for blonde men too he just he just
really destroyed himself marijuana who
it's like it's like um how Jay-Z got
like an afro but he looks cool now you
know what I mean like Jay-Z did it right
Brad Pit did it wrong she's with Alia
shaat remember Alia shaat from you know
I met her once in Oakland he's really
awkward she rush like oh my God I love
you she was having lunch and I was like
screaming at her it's kind of what I'm
known for
apparently screaming at Celebrities Just
sh say shook my do you get all worked up
when you see a celebrity I love
celebrities I know but like I see a
celebrity oh no no you have no idea no I
go crazy I I go well see I see a
celebrity I just
like I don't I just see them as another
person like you I saw Black China I was
like oh my God T celebrities are like
Gods they're beyond Gods I know they're
they're piece of [__] you know what I
mean I know what they've done they're
just humans like you and me well
Jennifer lawren [__] she did suck
Harvey Weinstein's dick I know this I've
seen footage someone showed me a video
of her sucking his dick
literally they all did it is the
question it's like it's in the [__]
documentary right I'm not not to say I'm
not a feminist but not only did Donald
Trump win the president Y which uh would
be impossible cuz he grabbed them right
by the [__] like how how did he
win how did he win because people like
every every time there was a a debate
like I remember there was a debate with
Trump like percentages right no but like
like the day the day before the debate
or the day of the debate the news came
out that he grabbed the women in the
elevator whatever he did so does it work
or doesn't it and it that's all everyone
talked about which means that Trump won
who cares what was said in the debate
he was in the news yeah exactly his name
was out there his name was out there her
name wasn't right yeah and it's just
saying the words crooked Hillary he
understands it it's not about having
good news about yourself it's it's not
her fault it's just she really wasn't
the most ultimate kind of it's like
she's the the Queen of Hearts you know
what I mean remember Helen B Carter
Queen Hearts like I love her I know
she's done some very awful [__] and
she's been through some very awful [__]
but I do love her I just don't think she
represents women at all because she goes
out of her way to present as a on pant
suits short
hair that that that way of talking you
know what I mean that that that
boardroom way of talking you know you
want your female president to be a
little bit sexy no not sexy just to
represent women all women to be not
overcompensating her Womanhood for the
sake of the presidency she's putting a
dick on to become president you know
mhm plus I know about the Benghazi thing
and email server oh my God she done some
[__]
I mean it's Freemasonry it's not it's
America I get it but um she would not
have been fit to be president let's say
she has done some very evil [__] I would
vote for her but honestly I prefer
Donald Trump just for the spectacle
which didn't even pan out it wasn't even
fun it wasn't even fun you know what I
mean could have been so
fun I mean ianka was a Goya I'm like
Bish like like I saw the humor but so if
I put you in a nice hotel rather than
just one of these skidrow hotels you
would stay or you would you run out yes
yes daddy yes so tonight I'm going to
put you in a nice hotel thank you Daddy
spend some money and put you in a nice
place thank you Daddy we'll see how you
do thank you Daddy if you're going to
run out and get high and I won't pick up
some [__] on my way
there just not the one not not the one
by the Armada not that one okay not that
part of to somewhere around here like I
say the hent I got an nice hotel not the
Hilton Mark or the Bel Mark that can you
no no no it would be nice you put me up
the Hilton chak is
but maybe we're a little premature on
that one yes or no Hilton checkers one
night no no no when iess oh I this
again see L is like a game of chest you
know what I mean and I'm always going to
play block well why why is it you think
you are using drugs and and so out of
control on the streets because you
nothing to do no be but is it because
you want so desperately to be a woman
and you're frustrated and you're just
losing your mind no no honestly it's
because I enjoy doing
drugs I'm going to raise a white flag
here and just go yeah but but I mean if
I didn't want to be doing drugs I
wouldn't be doing drugs but I can tell
you that being creative doing something
it also to be creative all artists do
drugs because of it Coke not all yeah
not all but like most even Damian Hurst
do LSD I don't love LSD I I'd rather be
loose I think you're a little bit too
focused on the drug thing I think we're
all a little too focused on the drug
thing I'm not
it's just honestly I spent so much in my
life like trying to get high like um
when I was at teer right I had no
friends no honestly and all I want to do
was smoke hash for the cool
kids what age was what age was this when
you had no friends
huh what age was this when you had no
friends I think today is as I said the
beginning of a beautiful relationship
yeah it feels like beautiful friendship
feels like it h this feels like it me
you and the devil oh okay must be a
devil between us
hey
hey hey been trying to meet
you hey must be a devil between us hey
must be or horns in my head hey so as
you know I have two horns and their name
are Mary K as
Mary Kate is in control and Ash is in
witchcraft so either
way house
Bells that's what I've been doing here
I've either been MK or I've been Ashley
just saying they're doing nothing or
completely [__] mind controlling for
some reason I thought I was
a a queen no the president
Noah agent Holly
Lightly for some reason I was under the
impression that I was to go to work for
the CIA or that I work for the CIA or
that I'd be the third female head of the
CIA or the fourth well because of Nikki
Haley I have some predecessors and their
names are well you're not going to post
this up it's way too long anyway Mar and
Mar one is my daughter and one is Mary
Kate's daughter and Nikki Haley is Nikki
Reid's daughter not Nikki's and Nikki
read is Pan's daughter meaning the grand
what's your ideal situation to be in in
5 years where would you like to be
living in The Stylist living in the US
SL living in the US stylist cretive
director w/ mayv or some kind of an up
magazine um dual residency Paris America
M honestly I've seen Paris La now
because I don't love New York like I
don't love New York I don't want to live
in New York I would but I love La so I
want to bring W to La cuz it makes more
sense cuz that's where all celebrities
are and W celebrity magazine work for w
in LA and uh split it between LA and
Paris and also what I really want to do
is I want to bring numu it's run by I
want to bring it to to America and run
num us but that will take a little bit
longer maybe 10 years 5ye goal W
magazine 10- year goal numo us wow good
for you yeah thank you Mark we can get
there I'm sure yeah yeah yeah I had a
dream last night Lucas zot came to me in
my dream and he was like all muscular
and he was trying to start with me Lucas
zot was homeless and then he um was cast
by a guy his name is
um his name oh [__] uh cuz I I ran into
him at the bookmark store at Mark
Jacob's bookstore Kevin um Kevin Amato
or something yeah Kevin Amato and he
cast him and then he ended up in V I
think or or maybe even W or ID or
something and then he was on that show
uh grownish now he's an actor and he's
very he's like young Hollywood he was
the the new rur and uh
perfume boy with lucky blue Smith first
black face of raw form perfumes was a
bum when I see the interviews honestly I
think of an old video of har enough
talking to V where he looked like [__] I
mean she looked like [__] if you ever
made it you'd have such a fascinating
story to go from where where you are now
to uh I wish I had more going on you I
me like I I wish I like become a
stripper or written a book or well
you're you're you're so young you can do
anything now I'm not young young as that
cuz you're 63 I swear I'm
26 I mean I'm like I'm like literally
like at the
[__] what's it called I'm I'm at the
plateau of uh of Aging out of the
industry I'm like right where the mouth
down happens right Britney
Lindsay
Paris not nikk but no I don't know right
when the mouth out happens right 26 it's
26 to 29 I think I think you could do
anything you want that's when the mouth
out happens except they all failed where
I will
succeed including Nikki who never became
a celebrity for some reason just stay a
socialite I mean she so much more I'd
love it if you watch that video could
you bring it up right now please here
tell you what before we go are you
hungry no but I'll go for
lunch but can you can you pull up the
video before we finish the interview
real quick yes what is the video just
write Nikki Hilton Rothchild W or Nikki
Hilton W it's and I kkii right yeah cuz
I really want to piss myself off right
now cuz she is my ideal daughter her
real name is
Nikolai on our way to the wedding it's
got to be difficult being a celebrity H
it's got to be difficult being a
celebrity you think she's a celebrity
well thank you for saying that I mean I
in the public she's um she's a socialite
Mar the same thing she's my daughter
she's the daughter I I um I mean she
thought I always wished I'd had but
honestly she really [__] up uh is that
a torch
ju sorry huh but your eyebrows kind of
remind me salushi anyway um yeah Nikki
Nikki it's all about Nikki for me if I'd
be a woman I'd be her you know it's kind
of why I'm dressed St like her today
just open her Alma Mo as I would say
this is Nikki Hilton
you Nikki
Hilton witch
you Dragon print coret
shear black PVC
shorties and a pair of sneakers just to
keep it
casual even though lately she's been
wearing floral print [__] midies and
uh heels had her hair done all block she
had her hair Block in 2006
2005 around at the same time press got
arrested for that bag of coke remember
press got arrested for a bag of coke and
weo and I got arrested for having a dick
than you West
Hollywood you want to say goodbye to
everybody all your fans bye everybody
sincerely Rebecca oleno the witch
Supreme vote now thank you Rebecca thank
you Mark on ww. tho.com that was fun you
log in and start watching
exclusive I'm if
to